Latin America and the Caribbean it is
good to be finally back together indeed
it has been eight years now that we have
seen each other in this form at last
time and it's been too long without any
question
for us Europeans
Latin America
and the Caribbeans are family
we read your great literature
you have heard that Borges has been
cited two times already
in this opening session but also
Gabrielle Garcia Marquez
we listen to your music
we love your football heroes
but most importantly we believe in the
same values we see the world with the
same eyes
we share the same faith in the United
Nations Charter we all build on it we
all defend it
all of us will never accept
that might makes right
but we want respect for the
international law
and respect for the U.N Charter
and you demonstrated that by your
support for the UN resolution concerning
Russia's War
and we thank you for that
we also share a very Lively network of
economic ties
if you look at our two-way trade for
instance it has grown by 40 percent in
the last four years
these deep connections have always kept
our two continents closed closed even
when we could not get together in a
Summit like this one
but I think and this was also the
subject of many of the speakers we are
far from fulfilling our great potential
there's a lot more to tap into
and in difficult time like ours our
partnership needs steering from the top
level
indeed today it feels like meeting an
old friend
is a beautiful words of the famous
vinicius de morayesh
we are bound to be together
we are bound to meet again
and this Summit marks A New Beginning
for the old friendship between the
European Union Latin America and the
Caribbean
the world around us is becoming more
conflictual and more competitive the
geopolitical instability is turning into
economic uncertainty
repercussions on the food and energy
security are difficult for our citizens
this happens at a time when climate
change is felt ever more dramatically by
our communities
El Nino returns
hurricanes and rising sea level threaten
lives and livelihoods especially in the
Caribbean
so more funding is needed for the
transition to clean energy and for
adaptation
the world has a thirst for predictable
long-term investments in climate-proof
infrastructure and in good jobs for our
citizens
in times like these
we need friends we can trust
true partners
to chart the way forward and shape the
future of our continents and I believe
this is also true for Latin America the
Caribbean and the European Union
our regions deserve substantial
Investments to push forward the green
transition
to bring new digital infrastructure to
the most remote parts of the continent
but also to keep moving up the global
value chain and bring more people from
poverty into the middle class
now in all these topics
Europe wants to partner with you
we want to be by your side
and therefore I'm glad today
to launch our investment agenda for
Latin America and the Caribbean
we call it global gateway
under the banner of global gateway we
propose to bring over 45 billion euros
of high quality European investment to
Latin America and the Caribbean
over 135 projects are already in the
pipeline
from clean hydrogen to critical raw
materials from the high performance data
cable network
to producing the most advanced mRNA
vaccines
or to critical raw materials where for
us is important
that there is not only the extraction
but that the value chain
stays locally so the processing that the
added value benefits the local
communities
only we together can of course agree on
sectors and value chains to priorities
to to prioritize
and how we can best boost these
Investments with skilled personnel
with standards
and of course with technical support so
let us use this Summit to shape the
investment agenda
to the benefit of both our continents
we are also closed not only to
finalizing some historic trade deals but
also to modernizing the agreements we
already have
we are done with Chile
we will be signing
tomorrow we are done with Argentina we
had the signing we're looking forward to
Mexico
and Marco sewer still this year lots of
work to do but very good work to do
this will help companies on both sides
of the Atlantic
to scale up
to plan for the future to attract new
investment
so let us commit to becoming even more
reliable Partners to each other
and finally
our political dialogue
all across both our continents and it's
tangible here in the room there's a new
willingness to engage
I've seen it and I've heard it during my
recent trip to your region
and the same willingness is very much
felt here in Europe
so let us turn this new phase
into a commitment to long-lasting
engagement
we should have closer
and more constant cooperation on the big
Global challenges we face and we will
discuss them here
at the United Nations at the G20 on
financing for climate on development and
on peace in respect for the
international law
let us truly make this moment a new
beginning
for Latin America the Caribbean and the
European Union welcome to Brussels
thank you madam president before we give
the flow to other distinguished leaders
we invite you to listen to the string
sex that composed by European and Latin
American artists the members of the
Brussels Philharmonic Orchestra and will
play two pieces graph